مقدار سبعه فاصل خمسه درجه على مقياس ضربت
جنوبيه تركيا نعود الى المنطقه ربما الاشد
في تركيا ما يتعلق بكهرمان مراش كان معنا
عمر حلبي قبل قليل نعود له ونتابع معه
مشاهدته عمرو
[موسيقى]
انا عبد
القادر التصدعات والشقوق التي احدثها
الزلزال خصوصا الزلزال الاول الذي بلغت
شدته 7.7 على مقياس ريختر وكان مركزه في
ناحيه براجيك في ولايه مراش في هذه
المنطقه التي نحن الان قريبون من ناحيه
برجك كان هنالك العديد من التشققات ومن
الصدوع والتصدعات التي كما قلت زادت نتيجه
الزلزال الثاني الذي حصل قبل نحو خمسه الى
عشر دقائق من الان
والهزات الارتداديه ما بين المتوسطه الى
الخفيفه تجري ما بين 2000 والاخرى على
جانبي الطريق هنالك العديد من المباني
والمعامل والمنشات التي رايناها قد اصابها
الدمار اما بشكل كامل او بشكل جزئي الان
بعد هذه الشاحنه تشاهدون ربما زميل مصور
سيحاول ان ينقل لكم الصوره هذا المعمل
اصابه ضرر جزء نتيجه
زلزال ومعمل اخر ايضا خلفه مصنع كذلك ايضا
تضرروا بشكل جزئي نتيجه الزلزال نريد بعض